okay so this video is about the
characteristics of blood and eventually
we're gonna go into blood typing and how
we solve problems associated with blood
transfusions so let's get started so
when we look at the components of blood
what blood is made from we can break
blood down into whole blood and plasma
first of all whole blood whole blood is
made from red blood cells and I think
you know the job of red blood cells is
the carry oxygen around to other cells
of the body you know red blood cells
only live for a few months and then they
die and dead red red blood cells are
filtered up by your liver filtered out
by your spleen and eventually excreted
in your feces it's kind of what gives
your poop it's darker color
we also look at white blood cells white
blood cells are another component of
what is called a whole blood and I have
a whole video on the immune system but
in general white blood cells fight
pathogens like bacteria and viruses and
then there's the third component of
whole blood what are called platelets
and these are fragments of cells that
help aid in a clot if you ever have an
injury so here we have a vein with red
blood cells and white blood cells and
pretend that you just this person just
cut themselves and as a result of the
cut look at this they're bleeding
they're bleeding out red blood cells and
white blood cells well what happens our
platelets are little cell fragments that
will help clot and seal the injury
now platelets alone do not form a blood
clot like this but there's platelets and
there's other clotting proteins that are
involved but in general that's kind of
the function of platelet you know when
we look at this test tube or this vial
of blood we can put it in a machine but
a centrifuge and it'll spin the blood
really fast and actually separate the
whole blood from the liquid part of
blood called plasma the whole blood the
red blood cells white blood cell right
white blood cells and platelets they
kind of sink to the bottom and on top is
this yellowish clear liquid called
plasma made up a 90% water and what's
dissolved in that plasma is a big list
of solutes and that's what you see right
here amino acids are
solutes salts and hormones and
antibodies of solutes these are all
dissolved in the watery plasma by the
way for those of you who might be
looking for a good community service
project no donating to a plasma donation
center your plasma will be collected and
used to create all kinds of therapies to
treat a variety of conditions and
disease it's a great way to to do some
community service so now I want to
mention the different types of blood the
different groups of blood and you're
gonna hear this referred to as the [ __ ]
blood groups or [ __ ] blood types and the
reason that other the way that a blood
type gets its name is based on what are
called antigens on the surface of red
blood cells there are these lumps of
proteins called antigens and we can
symbolize these proteins with with
various letters of our alphabet here if
we zoom on in and we look at this red
blood cell here I'm not trying to imply
that there are English shaped A's on our
on our red blood cells but if you have
type A blood you have a protein on the
surface of your red blood cells that we
just call the a type protein if you have
type B blood that you have various
proteins on the surface of your red
blood cells that we happen to call these
proteins the B type protein this is an
example of an antigen if you have type a
B blood you have a combination not just
the a type proteins but also the B type
proteins and so you have these two
antigens you have the a antigen and the
B antigen and if you have type O blood
you don't have either of those so it's
almost like it's a it's almost like a
cell with no aunt actually it is a cell
that has no antigens none of these
proteins on its surface and so the
purpose of these antigens the purpose of
these proteins is they help to identify
cells that belong to yourself or cells
that belong to a foreign invader such as
a bacteria such as a virus our immune
system will attack whatever enters our
body that has a different set of
antigens than our own so the analogy I
like to make is that antigens are like
the jerseys of a sports team your immune
system has the same Jersey as all the
other cells of
body and if something gains entrance
into your body like a bacteria like a
virus it's gonna have a different Jersey
it's gonna have a different set of
antigens your immune system will
recognize that and then attack and
destroy your often gonna see antibodies
kind of just illustrated as a y-shaped
protein it is a protein and the way that
the amino acids are arranged they
actually are arranged in the shape of
the letter Y so it's very typical to
just see them symbolically shown in the
drawing as in an animation as just a
y-shaped item and so here's a blood vein
with some Y's traveling through the
blood vein so these Y's are symbolic of
our of antibodies and there's a virus
pretend well notice there's a little
bumps sticking out of the body of the
virus those little bumps our antigens
and because those antigens belong to the
virus and not belong to our own body our
antibodies will recognize those little
bumps those antigens and will attack
they'll attach to those little antigens
and they'll cause the virus or the
bacteria to be destroyed I have a whole
video on the immune system if you want
to check that out but that's the general
light so let's focus on blood type a
first again remember blood type a has
these a antigens on the outside of the
red blood cells while flowing through
the vein in the plasma are these B
antibodies antibodies as we're gonna
learn attack antigens we just don't want
our antibodies to attack our antigens we
want our antibodies to attack antigens
of viruses and bacteria not ourselves so
notice how the antigen a does not match
the antibody B if they did match they
would attack each other so what would
happen now if this virus that has B
antigens on the outside were to somehow
get into your blood I hope you see what
would happen the B antibodies will
attack and swarm attach itself to those
B antigens that are sticking out of the
virus and ultimately those B antibodies
would destroy the virus a great way for
our immune system to keep us healthy
what we have to be careful about
is if in a blood transfusion let's say
this person who has type A blood lost a
lot of blood and they were taken to the
hospital and they were given somebody's
blood type B I hope you see a problem
here what would happen if you gave this
person type D blood your antibodies
would attack your body doesn't know the
difference between this type B blood and
the virus that had the B antigens you
saw just a moment ago your immune system
would attack this donated blood and it
would cause all of us donate a blood to
clump together and form little blood
clots all throughout your veins so it
would stop blood flow and ultimately
stop circulation and the person would
most likely die from this so you have to
be very careful if we looked at type B
blood notice how the antigens are
different type B because they have the B
antigens so that's the definition really
have type B blood the red blood cells
have the B antigens on their surface
that means they're going to have the a
antibodies floating through their veins
the a antibodies are gonna attack
anything that has an a antigen which
would probably be a virus or a bacteria
so what would happen in our animation if
a virus with a antigens were to somehow
invade your blood I hope you see that we
have a defense for that those a
antibodies would swarm attach itself to
the virus and ultimately cause it to be
destroyed that's awesome but we have to
be careful because in a blood
transfusion if this person had type B
blood and we accidentally gave them type
A blood in the transfusion our immune
system is going to see that type A blood
and because we have a antibodies that
this person has a antibodies those a
antibodies will attack and swarm those a
antigen blood cells and would cause like
we saw a moment ago all those blood
cells to clump together cause little
blockages and little clots inside your
veins and arteries and chances are this
person will not survive this mistake
what about type a B blood well if they
have type a B blood notice on the red
blood cells there's both the a protein
and the B protein the a antigen and the
B antigen well can you predict the
antibodies that they will have well they
have an A antibody
well they have a b antibody well they
have both or they have neither well i
hope you can see that they don't have
either in this case because if they did
if they had an a antigen it would attack
i said that wrong if they had an EI
antibody if this person had an EI
antibody flowing through their veins it
would attack those antigens you see in
the picture if this person had B
antibodies flowing through their veins
it would attack the B antigens that you
see in the picture so what would happen
if this person was invaded by the
viruses below are there any antibodies
to attack either of those viruses I hope
you see no they don't have any
antibodies to attack these viruses so
these viruses would have to be destroyed
by other means other parts of the immune
system besides the antibodies so in a
blood transfusion what if you gave this
person as type a B blood what if you
gave them blood type a in a transfusion
is there anything to attack that donated
blood what would happen if he gave this
this person blood type A nothing Bad's
gonna happen because there's no a
antibodies to attack those a antigens
same thing what if you gave this person
who has type a B blood what if you gave
them the B blood in a transfusion
do they have B antibodies to attack no
they don't so nothing bad is gonna
happen it's safe
this person can accept type A blood you
saw a moment ago and they can also
accept type B blood that you see right
now they don't have B antibodies to
attack those B antigens nothing bad
would happen so let's look at the last
blood type really quick Type O or group
O blood it's called group OB oh no oh no
means it doesn't have any any of these
antigens no a antigen no B antigen so
it's a red blood cell with neither of
those antigens on its surface so if they
don't have the antigens
can you predict what antibodies they
will have I hope you saw a pattern with
the other types of blood that we talked
about if they don't have an antigen they
do have an antibody that's a pattern I
hope you picked up on so because they
have they don't have an a antigen they
do have an antibody because they don't
have an A because they don't have a B
antigen they do have a B antibody so
what would happen if this person was
invaded by the the virus's below you can
see the virus on the left has B antigen
antigens and the virus on the right has
a antigens well I hope you would see
that the antibodies that are flowing
through the vein will attack the virus
on the top right the a antigen virus is
going to be attacked by a antibodies
causing the virus to be destroyed the
virus that remains in the middle of the
picture has B antigens it's going to be
attacked by B antibodies they attach to
the the antigens and antibodies attached
to one another and the virus is
destroyed so think about a blood
transfusion what if this person has Type
O blood and you gave them someone's
blood type a well this caused a reaction
I hope you can see that this would be a
very dangerous situation because they
have a antibodies flowing through their
veins those a antibodies would attach to
the a antigens and would cause it would
cause the blood to clump together
causing these little blood clots all
throughout the person's veins and
stopping circulation this person would
most likely not survive this movie well
let's look at another situation again
they have type-o blood but what if you
gave them type B in a transfusion I hope
you see another problem here this person
has B antibodies those B antibodies will
think the body's under attack by a virus
or a bacteria and they're gonna swarm
and attack those those blood cells that
you're trying to give the person to save
their life causing the antibodies to
react that clumps up the entire group of
cells there and causes little blood
clots all over the person's body they're
probably not going to survive that
mistake
what about this situation what if you
gave them type a B blood I hope you see
that this is a mistake as well this
probably kill the person as well because
they have not just the a antibody but
also the B antibody and the a antibodies
will attach to the a antigens and also
the B antibodies will attach to the B
antigens and all these cells will clump
together causing little blood clots all
throughout the person's body and the
chances chances are very high that the
person is going to die from this mistake
so this is a really good place to pause
the video if you just want to check out
this table really quick to see what is
the difference between antigen and
antibodies of the various blood types so
pause the video if you like I'm gonna
continue so here's a little practice
problem let's pretend that you have type
a have covered out covered the other
blood type let's pretend you have type a
can you receive type A blood type B
blood type a B and type O blood in the
transfusion pause the video think about
it yourself I'm gonna go for the answers
in three two one
so you really want to look at what
antibodies does the person have if they
have type A blood this person has B
antibodies these B antibodies will
attack anything with a B antigen don't
give this person any kind of blood with
B antigens so look at our list on the
right if you have type A blood can you
receive type A blood yes because there's
no B antigens in type A blood the next
one if you have type A blood can you
receive type B blood no because type B
blood has B antigens that's why it's
called type B blood how about the next
one if you have type A blood can receive
type a B blood no because there's a be
in a B blood that would cause your the
antibodies to attack and then the last
one if you have type A blood can you
receive Type O blood
yeah that's safe Type O does not have B
antigens here's another question right
here if you have type B blood can you
receive type a Type B type a B Type O
pause the video think about it on your
own I'm gonna go over the answers in
three two one so if you have type B
blood you got it
consider what antibodies does do does
this person have they have the a
antibody any antibodies will attack a
antigens don't give this person anything
with an a antigen so if you're type B
blood can you get type A no type a has
an a antigen if you have type B can you
receive Type B yes you can always
receive your own blood type the next one
if you have type B blood can you receive
Type A B blood no type a B blood has an
a antigen and lastly if you have type B
blood can you receive Type O blood yes
that's safe there
Type O has no antigen so there's nothing
to attack so I hope you see the pattern
here here's a Type A B same question
pause the video I'm gonna go over the
answers in three two one
so if you have type a B blood now you
have to remember that they don't have
either a nor the B antibodies so they
don't have antibodies antibodies do the
attacking and this person doesn't have
antibodies that should tell you that all
the blood types are safe if they don't
have antibodies they don't have anything
to attack the donated blood so here's
the last one again pause the video I'm
gonna start going over these answers in
three two one
so if you have type O blood you got to
remind yourself that there's two
antibodies you have to be careful of
this person has an antibody don't give
this person anything with an a antigen
and they also have a B antibody so don't
give this person anything with a B
antigen so a and B antigens are
off-limits
so you go down the list if you have type
O blood can you receive type A blood no
because there's an a antigen on type A
and they're a antibodies will attack it
if you the next one if you have type O
blood can you receive type B blood no
because type B blood has a B antigen and
this person has B antibodies the next
one if you have Type O can you receive
type a B that's a double no type a B has
a and B antigens this person has a and B
antibodies and then the last one if you
have Type O can you receive Type O yes
you can always receive your own blood
type so again here's a good place to
pause the video and just study this
table if if if you want to see some of
the differences between the antigens and
antibodies of the various blood types so
the last thing I want to mention is what
is called the RH fact that you may have
heard that some blood might be positive
blood or negative blood this is what we
mean by the Rh factor a person has
positive blood Rh positive a person has
positive blood if they contain another
antigen called the RH antigen remember
antigens are like jerseys and in my
picture you can see that there's an a
antigen in the picture there's also an
RH antigen that means this person has
type it is blood type a positive in this
picture right here you can see that
there's a B antigen and an RH antigen
this is blood type B positive in this
picture right here you can see there's a
antigens and B antigens and now I've
also added RH antigens this person's
blood type is a B positive
and in this picture right here hey
there's no antigens but now I've just
added the RH antigens so if there's only
RH antigens this is blood type O
positive so if we look at all four of
them together notice that what they all
have in common the positives all have
the RH antigen in common well if you
have an antigen you do not have an
antibody that's something that a pattern
I hope you picked up earlier and so if
you're positive here if your blood type
positive then you can receive positive
or negative blood in a blood transfusion
we're gonna go over some of the reasons
why in just a few moments so what's it
mean to have negative blood type if you
have a negative blood type that means
that you lack this RH antigen so cells
lack the RH antigen right now in the
picture there is a positive but if I
take away those are H's it's not a
positive any
now that's blood type a-negative a
moment ago we saw this type be positive
but if I take away those are ages it's
not be positive anymore it's just be
negative a moment ago we saw this a B
and Rh that's a B positive but if I take
away those are H's it's not a B+ it's
just a be negative now and a moment ago
we saw this only our H's is o+ but if I
take away those our H's it's not all
positive its own negative so when you
look at the four blood types that are
negative and look what the one thing
they all have in common is that they
lack the RH antigen but they do contain
the RH antibodies
I hope you picked up on the rule if you
have an antigen you don't have an
antibody if you don't have an antigen
you do have an antibody and if you have
this RH antibody that means you're only
going to be able to receive negative
blood if you have negative blood and you
were to receive positive blood in the
transfusion you're probably not going to
survive that mistake because the RH
antibodies will attack the positive RH
antigens so if we look at this picture
here here are the eight different blood
types the four positives and the four
negatives think about what blood type
are you well around the world about 34%
of people around the world are a
positive the 9% are be positive 3% are a
B positive
38% are Oh positive 6% are a negative 2%
are being negative only 1% are a be
negative and only 7% are own negative so
the positives are the much more common
blood types around the world but if you
might know what blood type you are and
then you can just kind of see where you
fit into this so let's go over a few
practice problems let's pretend that a
person has blood type B positive begin
by thinking what antigens does a person
have well if they're B positive they do
not have an antigen if they're B
positive yes they have a B antigen and
the positive the positive means yes they
have an RH antigen so what antibodies do
they have well the pattern I hope you
picked up on earlier as if you don't
have an antigen you do have an antibody
so this person does not have an a
antigen so yes they have an a antibody
they're just opposites if you have a B
antigen you do not have a B antibody if
you have an RH antigen you do not have
an RH antibody so you look at this put
our question right here what blood types
can safely be donated to this person if
your B positive you have to keep in mind
that if your B positive this person has
a antibodies like my note says don't
give this person anything with an a
antigen look at the the eat choices at
the bottom cross out any choice that has
an A in it that would be a positive that
would be a negative that would be a B
positive that would be a B negative the
other four choices are safe these four
choices that I crossed out you would
accidentally kill this person most
likely kill the person if you gave them
the wrong blood type
here's another practice problem go ahead
and pause at this time and try to solve
it I'm gonna go over the answers in
three two one
so if your a B positive what antigens do
you have a B positive you have the a you
have the B and the positive means yes
you have the RH antigen so what
antibodies well if you have an antigen
you don't you don't you don't have an
antibody so here's the question you saw
a moment ago which blood types can be
safely donate to this person all of them
since antibodies attack and this person
has no antibodies they don't have
anything to attack donated blood all of
these are safe that's why a B+ is called
the universal acceptor the universal
receiver they can receive they can
accept any type of blood out there
how about this one if you're o+ what
antigens
do you have pause the video I'm gonna go
over the answers in three two one if
you're o+ o means no no you don't have
an A no you don't have a B but the
positive means yes you have an RH so
what antibodies again the rule is if you
have one you don't have the other so if
you don't have an antigen YES on the a
antibody YES on the B antibody but they
have an RH antigen that means they know
will not have an RH antibody so here's
that question you saw which blood types
can be safe it can safely be donated to
this person you have to keep two things
in mind first thing they have an A and
two they have an antibody so don't give
this person anything with an a antigen
look at the bottom cross out everything
with an a antigen I just crossed out
four of them that have a antigens but
the second thing we have to keep in mind
they also have a B antibody antibody so
they also have B antibodies so don't
give this person anything with a B
antigen and I just crossed out the last
two that had B antigens the ones that
are not crossed out o+ o- those are safe
here's another one if you have a B
negative
what antigens does this person have a B
means they have the a and the B the
negative the negative means no on the RH
antigen so when antibodies do you have
it's either one or the other if you have
an antigen then no on the a antibody if
you have a B antigen then no on the B
antibody and if you don't have an
antigen then yes you're gonna have the
antibody so here's that question with
the eight blood types which blood types
can safely be donated to this person
well this person has RH antibodies be
careful you don't want these RH
antibodies to attack anything so what do
RH antibodies attack they attack RH
antigens what kind of blood has RH
antigens positive blood so eliminate all
the positive options the other four
negative options are safe here's another
one type o-negative
what
Tian's does this person have o means no
no on the a no on the be the negative
means no on the RH so if they don't have
any of those antigens I hope you see the
pattern yes yes yes on the three
antibodies so here's the question of
these eight what can safely be donated
to this person start with antibody a
this person has antibody a it will
attack a antigens cross out everything
that has an a antigen I just cross out
those four because they all have a
antigens we're not done though this
person also has B antibodies B
antibodies will attack the antigens
cross out any choices that have B
antigens and I just crossed out those
two we're not done yet though because
this person has a third antigen the
third antibody this person has the RH
antibody which will attack RH antigens
cross out any of the remaining choices
that have RH antigens that would be
positive blood so the only one that's
not crossed off if you're o-negative you
can only receive O Negative so there you
go
if you're in my biology class you know
you can pause this video and try to
answer these review questions right here
I'd love to check your answers either
before school or after school one day so
bring them on in I'll check them over
for accuracy and good luck pause the
video and try to solve